j'ai voulu pour moi autoportraits qui ma
fibre habran soit la très des mois avec
moi pourquoi parce que toute ma vie a
été marquée par les enfants puis quand
je regarde regarde barbara je vois toute
ma vie dans ma barre dans son visage
je sais bien que tout le monde pour tout
le monde les enfants sont importantes et
pour comprendre ce qu'il représente pour
moi un enfant il faut que je reviens
dans ses années au début de la guerre
quand j'étais un enfant moi même et
quand des nazis ils sont rentrés de
marsovie du jour au lendemain parce que
j'étais juif moi-même mes frères toute
ma famille nous avons été des enfants
exclus voué à la mort et j'ai dû
survivre
je suis né donc avec la guerre c'est à
dire si je dis questionner avec la
guerre parce que la guerre a commencé
pour nous les polonais en 1939 en effet
que je suis très à cheval avant la
guerre mais ces années didou sert de
bonheur familial
je me souviens de prat pas du tout c'est
très flou je suis né d'une famille
modeste
si j'avais des frères deux frères qui se
fait avec moi déporté à treblinka avec
moment ils sont morts tous morts dans
les chambres à gaz mort également son
110 membres de nos familles des oncles
et tantes des grands-parents des
cousines des enfants beaucoup d enfants
mon père tué devant mes yeux je suis le
seul survivant de soucis nul 110
personnes
un sauveteur et porte-parole et quand
j'ai réfléchi à mon enfance
et quand je vois autour de moi souvent
des gens je me dis et que je ne voudrais
pas qu'il ya des enfants par le monde
qui connaissent et l'expérience que j'ai
moi même rencontré
qu'est ce que c'était que cette
expérience
cette expérience était dans les ghetto
de varsovie
l'expérience de la guerre et non
seulement l'expérience de la guerre
l'expérience de la barbarie c'est à dire
que j'ai vu je vis qui l'homme pouvait
se transformer en animal je vis ce sont
les mots que j'emploie dans mon livre au
nom de tous les miens je vis des animaux
au visage dont et ça je vous avoue moi
qui venais de jamie unis moi qui venais
de famille où le bonheur la fraternité
et les deux autres essais les règles de
la vie
brusquement affronter ces animaux au
visage dont c'est au manoir a été pour
moi une expérience terrible j'avais 13
14 ans et du jour au lendemain je me
suis vite devenu une bête traquée pire
qu'une bête traquée un enfant pourchassé
par des bourreaux par des animaux au
visage dont ils ont essayé de me tuer
j'ai dû vite apprendre à reconnaître
dans les yeux de nos la haine ou
l'amitié jeu suivant village on ne m'a
collé contre admire on a tiré sur moi et
je vais mourir les miens tout le mien et
je pars le nom ici m'ont mis dans des
camps était impossible de croire qu'un
enfer paris existait et qu'il dise on
pouvait imaginer même mais je vis aussi
dans les idées on de la solidarité et la
fraternité
et je crois que c'est extrêmement
important pour moi est d'avoir découvrir
dans sept camps de treblinka par exemple
ou alors amoureuse est partout deux
hommes étaient capables de partager leur
pain désormais capable passagers qui
coule plus précieux coq et leur pain la
dernière partie de l'air et force
physique pour m'aider moi moi qui
n'étais rien pour elle et qu'elle ferait
un malheur
et cette expérience pour un t6 vitalsys
ici capital qui j'avais jamais oublier
qu'à côté des mâles et qu'à côté des
bourreaux et qu'à côté des animaux au
visage dont l'homme est capable de
prendre et de garder les visages des
biens dans l'enfer je raconterai la
solidarité
la fraternité est gentil mais confirmé
ce que mon père m'a toujours dit que
tout est possible tout est possible cela
veut dire que la fraternité possible et
c'est grâce à cette mode et fraternité
cet enseignant de mon père tu vas pas de
la solidarité de l'amour que je suis
arrivé parchemin douloureuse jusqu'à ici
les questions étaient dans une commune
ville dans une ville au coeur de la
ville de varsovie
mon père s'occupait surtout des gens qui
n'avaient pas de logement et mois
montrent acheter les nourrir nos
familles puisque l'année ghetto c'est
surtout les enfants qu'ils ont eus
ouvrit les adultes je suis devenu
contrebandiers il fallait survivre il va
le vivre nourrir ma famille je suis
partie par l'étranger qui traversait la
ghetto parce que pour les polonais pour
traverser d'un côté à l'autre il fallu
traverser absolument par les ghettos
donc elles viennent travailler qui
passaient les ghettos et 20 policiers
polonais qui gave s est rangée qui
perçoit une rente ou sort et par cette
moyenne geste sourdine plusieurs fois
par jour un citoyen les policiers
polonais et finalement je suis devenu
que je peux appeler les plus grandes
profits qu'en contrebas dans des ghettos
et je ne suis fier de le dire parce que
grâce à moi et beaucoup de jeunes des
enfants comme moi que les gâteaux vivait
et quant aux nazis ils ont décidé de
liquider le ghetto à 1140 et des cèpes
l'humain et mes fraises ont été raflés
par magasin quand je suis allé avec et
dans les colonnes parce que je pensais
peut-être pour uche les aider à évadés
parce que je suis devenu moi même une
maître d'évasion je suis plusieurs fois
été arrêtés
la différence quand l'avant prison
jamais aucune mur jamais aucun prison
haute un assez gros pour moi
malheureusement quand ils sont arrivés à
tribunes quand ils n'avaient pas le
moyen de s'évader
ma mère mes frères sont allés vers les
chambres à gaz
moi je suis resté prisonnier les camps
de treblinka étaient divisés dans des
parties un parti était proprement dit
les chambres à gaz
finalement je me suis trouvée là-bas
comme prisonnier et montage était là-bas
de sortir des cadavres des chambres à
gaz pour les gt dans les fossés et
parfois il m'arrive est de trouver des
petits enfants qui s'est encore à la
moitié vivant et nous les prisonniers
nous avons l'étrangleur de jeu
proprement pour l'éviter simplement
qu'ils sont pas enterrés vivants